let's talk reese how the hell did she
build a company's worth 900 million
dollars what is this thing
okay so it's actually a really she built
it in an interesting way um
blackstone backed a media venture
that bought hello sunshine her
independent media company
uh production company for 900 million so
hello sunshine
she didn't start out building a
production company basically what
happened
was um it grew out of a book club
that she had that was similar to oprah's
book club
so it was called reese's book club and
it curates
titles and books uh for readers it holds
events for
its members um and it was focused on
women centric content
and so then reese was like hold on a
second
you mean to tell me that i can turn some
of these books
into movies and at the time um she had
found success as an actress in her 20s
she was kind of america's sweetheart but
then when she hit
age 36 she wasn't she wasn't finding
roles that she wanted
uh she was kind of tired of the rom-com
situation
and um she said
what if like why aren't there more
movies
more age-appropriate movies for women my
age basically um
and she created hello sunshine which is
an independent
production company focused on
women-centric
content produced by women
so she is producing the movies or
they're just
financing and somebody else is making
them both
uh she is producing and starring in some
of the movies like
cheryl strade's novel wild as well as
big little lies
she both produced and starred in it
uh baller do we have financials in terms
of how big the company actually is like
if it's worth 900 million for them to
buy it
do we know exactly what the revenue or
profits are or
or they didn't uh tell us that they
didn't
explicitly say but they did say hello
sunshine will be profitable this year
interesting so you'll like this hold on
just really quickly
um what what will i like
you'll like this so uh the ceo that she
hired for uh hello sunshine is sarah
hardin
who was the president of otter media a
privately held
joint venture between att and the
churnin group
uh where sarah spearheaded otter's first
investment in hello century
got it so charnin is an investor in
hello sunshine
basically yeah the churning group for
those that don't know i think
are probably the best media investors uh
in the world
they're the ones who did uh bar stool
and a bunch of others uh they've really
really just been ahead of uh ahead of
the curve
so how much does re-zone do we know
i don't know we don't know that uh it
feels like
if she stole the company for 900 million
she probably owns somewhere let's say
between 20 to 50 percent is my guess
uh which means that witherspoon now is a
sent a millionaire
and is she gonna stay on with the
company in terms of uh
what they're gonna do with it now now
that they've bought it yeah i believe so
and i think they now own
her um because the book club is under
hello sunshine
uh last year her net worth was estimated
to be around 200 million
uh so now the sale probably push her up
there
probably not a billionaire yet unlike
rihanna
got it and so when you think about uh
the opportunity here is this something
where they're just going to stay in
movies or are they eventually going to
go into podcasts and all that or we
don't know
yeah i think they already have actually
um they also have merch they have a
hello sunshine
merch store and i try to find out how
much it makes i couldn't
but um it sells like shirts tote bags
pens all sorts of things um and it has a
very
loyal base of people but i just think it
it's very interesting to me how
women like reese basically this grew out
of
a book club nobody saw it coming um
uh gwyneth paltrow her company
grew out of a curation newsletter that
used to
write in like 2008 it's just you can
back your way into a massive
business just by you know being like
seeing the demand
um and yeah it's i
i just i think it's interesting because
uh she's taken
female-centered projects where everybody
in hollywood was saying like
there's not really a demand for this
type of content
and she's not only shown that there is
demand
like they've won emmys and oscars and
things like that so it shows that
it can be they're critically acclaimed
and there's demand from viewers
yeah what's crazy to me about these is
uh gwyneth paltrow rhys witherspoon
uh a number of examples we have they
start out kind of very
uh modest in their ambition in terms of
uh just trying to build an audience or
build a community
and then they grow into these massive
things uh i think goop
is now valued at over a billion dollars
if i'm not mistaken
uh this is 900 million she should have
been able to eke out an extra 100 mil
there just to get to a billion says she
built a billion dollar business
um but it's really incredible that it
ultimately starts with just community
right how do you get the community and
then once they get the community then
they're able to kind of really
hit the uh hit the inflection point and
not only is it how do you get the
community but how do you build
relationships with authors which is what
i think helped her
when you know all sorts of like
executives are bidding for the rights to
turn this book into a show or a movie
reese kind of has first dibs because she
already has the relationships with the
authors
yeah what do you guys think about uh
hello sunshine
getting bought for 900 million dollars
i'm impressed i didn't even know it
existed last year
it's crazy one thing i think that's
really impressive is she's kind of taken
this different approach and like
transitioned into her career so you see
very few actors
and actresses basically continue to get
those star roles as they get older right
so you see like the samuel jacksons the
robert de niros
um but she has over imdb has
her reported with over 27 different
producer credits um and basically 20 of
those have come since 2016 when hello
sunshine was formed
right so she's basically she's branding
herself and her name and uh continuing
continuing her legacy in the media and
movie space which is amazing
uh plano rihanna today it was publicly
announced or confirmed that she is a uh
a billionaire
what do we think are we impressed do we
think there's anything else to uh to
read into it
yeah i think people have been like
sleeping on that story everybody when
they think like
you know uh business boss in the
entertainment world people typically
point to beyonce
but rihanna has always been the you know
the quiet
underrated person and then i i've known
about
her for a long time and i know she i
knew she was making a lot of money
i just didn't know how much yeah
i'm trying to find right now uh how much
money
um they actually are uh
making but it just says that it was
valued at 900 million
uh which seems a little uh crazy
but what's fascinating here's a detail
for you
she sold the business to a new media
company
that new media company one of the people
who is running it is kevin mayer
many people may remember kevin mayer
because kevin mayer is the guy who left
disney
uh after he was passed over for the ceo
job and he became the ceo of
tick tock was there for a short period
of time and then he ended up leaving and
now this is the next thing he's doing so
he just bought this 900 million dollars
uh
pretty cool did you see what he said
about it what th this
quote scared me a little bit it said uh
it's not a production company first of
all
it's a pretty well configured multiple
business line company and it's really
just a next generation company
i don't really know what that means but
that they have their hands and i mean i
i got the part of like it's not it
has a bunch of different facets but uh
when someone starts calling something
next generation company that's a little
yeah we're next generation too no
problem
i think that blackstone gave them two
billion dollars to keep
buying things up and it says that this
is part of a plan to build an
independent entertainment company for
hollywood's
streaming era and i think they probably
him and um tom staggs also at disney
alum have a better chance of doing that
than quibby you know my stuff with
quibby
you guys ever heard no let's hear it
basically i was like i'm a millennial
and i don't
want this sorry
i think we no go ahead let's go tell us
you are at work
offering no you're good
okay uh basically i said that
i was like i'm a millennial and
this is for millennials and i do not i
will not pay for quibby there's a bunch
of things why would i pay for quibby and
it didn't work
and i've been saying that since day one
she literally she was right
she was writing and people at uh that
read the
um uh term sheet were like well give
them a chance like be nice and blind is
like no i'm literally their target
demographic and i'm not going to watch
them saying i don't want it
yeah this is ridiculous uh some people
are saying that kevin mayer who i don't
know
um you know obviously he rose the ranks
in disney if everything that i've heard
everyone
uh really really respects him and thinks
of him as a uh
a very high quality uh effective
operator they're saying that he got
screwed
at uh tick tock we have any thoughts
there
um no i didn't know how he got screwed
but well i think he went there
and was not expecting uh to walk into
regulatory backlash
yeah and then all of a sudden there's
regulatory backlash and i think that who
knows who initiated it but there was a
uh hey i didn't sign up for this yeah i
mean if blackstone's gonna give someone
two billion dollars to go attack like
the streaming error though and say hey
look we need you to go acquire a bunch
of businesses to go build this
uh this business unit like he's probably
a pretty good guy to go do that
he's probably one of the best people to
go do it yeah paulina
yeah do we have you all right there you
are uh when we think about this
um are any of these things so the
company previously produced
big little lies the morning show on
apple tv plus
little fires everywhere uh
yeah all of those have you ever seen any
of
those
no so who do we think is it just because
they're on streaming platforms that you
don't watch or
like what do we think the audience for
this is
is it millennial women some of them but
like my mom
watches it i think i think it's actually
more for
the moms of millennials and
it makes sense as to what she wants to
do
in terms of targeting an older
demographic hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it
you